los ucranianos merecen todo nuestro
apoyo porque ellos se están peleando por
nosotros si ellos no lo detienen
tendremos que hacerlo nosotros en unos
años
la voz de este estudiante reunido junto
a varios centenares de personas para
manifestar su apoyo a ucrania es la de
muchos europeos que salen a las calles s
la semana pasada para rechazar la
invasión rusa en frankfurt alemania una
multitud se congregó para escuchar el
mensaje del presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski en una transmisión
por zoom lo mismo sucedió en tíflis
georgia un país que ya sufrió una
invasión rusa hace 14 años
y la solidaridad hacia la causa
ucraniana incluso ha dado un impulso a
esta fábrica en el suroeste de ohio
abrumada por pedidos de banderas de ese
país
y llegué el lunes y tenía algunos
correos de diferentes vendedores del
país sumaban un poco más de un centenar
y para el martes o miércoles hasta hoy
totalizamos más de 500 banderas en este
momento
en lisboa las manifestaciones en apoyo a
ucrania se apostaron frente a las
embajadas con un asiento en el consejo
de seguridad de la onu y en bruselas lo
hicieron frente a la sede de la otan
para apoyar el reclamo ucraniano de una
zona de exclusión aérea incluso en china
los atletas ucranianos se reunieron poco
antes de la inauguración de los juegos
paralímpicos de invierno de beijing para
pedir el fin de la invasión y recibieron
el respaldo de sus compañeros de otros
países pero en europa no hay unanimidad
en serbia un país que mantiene lazos
políticos étnicos y hasta religiosos con
rusia cientos de personas marcharon en
apoyo a ese país se trata de salvar la
humanidad rusia defiende a la humanidad
la civilización y la iglesia ortodoxa es
una batalla del bien contra el mal y
sabemos gloria al señor que la madre a
rusia ganará
donde grupos de voluntarios se empacaba
en ayuda humanitaria destinado a ucrania
una madre compartió la carta de su hija
de 10 años en la que se declaraba muy
joven para ayudar pero dedicaba sus
oraciones a las víctimas